It looks like the House of Mouse has delivered
a live-action fable worthy of a king.
First reactions are pouring in for Disney's
live-action remake of the classic 1994 animated
film The Lion King, and they're full of nothing
but praise for the movie's stunning visuals
and brilliant voice performances.
"Oh, goody."
That The Lion King is being heralded as a
landmark in photorealistic computer animation
shouldn't come as a surprise.
The movie is the handiwork of director Jon
Favreau, who pulled off something
similar with his 2016 live-action remake of
The Jungle Book.
At the time, that movie was also widely praised
for its deeply detailed and meticulously rendered
CGI characters.
For The Lion King, Favreau worked with a screenplay
by Jeff Nathanson, who previously worked on
Catch Me If You Can, The Terminal and Pirates
of the Caribbean: Dead Men Tell No Tales.
He also had the pleasure of presiding over
a cast that included some of Hollywood's hottest
stars.
Folks who caught preview screenings for The
Lion King quickly flocked to Twitter to heap
praise on the flick.
Actress and cosplayer extraordinaire Mica
Burton gushed over the movie's faithfulness
to the original, while expressing appreciation
for its more modern touches.
She wrote:
"The Lion King… was more than anything I
ever could've wanted.
It was BEAUTIFULLY animated, paid the highest
of honors to the original, and was packed
with modern humor."
The Wrap senior film reporter Beatrice Verhoeven
was in full agreement, bursting with praise
for pretty much every aspect of the film,
in particular the performance of a certain
pop music powerhouse.
She tweeted:
"Oh man #TheLionKing delivers.
It's a visual masterpiece that will leave
you smiling and crying the whole time.
It's a true testament to the lasting effect
Disney movies have on all generations.
Timon and Pumbaa steal the show.
And BEYONCE!!!"
Screen Picks editor and critic Kit Bowen acknowledged
that the original film set a high bar to live
up to but admitted the remake won her over
nonetheless.
She wrote:
"Did we need a live-action version of #TheLionKing?
Maybe not.
The OG Lion King still holds my heart forever,
but this version is beautifully crafted by
Jon Favreau, aptly voiced by great talent
and [gave] me all the feels [of] being back
on Pride Rock."
Collider's Steve Weintraub wrote that the
house came down at his screening, and predicted
a colossal box office win for Disney.
He tweeted:
"Been lucky to have attended a number of world
premieres but not sure I've ever heard as
much clapping during a movie as I did tonight
at #TheLionKing.
Was like being at a rock concert.
Movie is going to make so much money."
One of the few criticisms of the movie came
from ScreenRant and Forbes critic Alisha Grauso
who first tweeted:
"The Lion King is a dazzler.
Gorgeous score, spot-on voice acting, but
mostly, yeah, those visuals."
She then followed up with:
"That being said, #TheLionKing does illustrate
the limitations of projecting human emotions
onto photorealistic animals that can't convey
human expression."
Also less than enthralled with the movie was
Mashable editor Angie J. Han, who questioned
the value of such an uber-faithful remake
while conceding that a lot of skill went into
making it.
She wrote:
"#TheLionKing is exactly as advertised: a
beat-for-beat remake of the original.
Impressive animation and some ace casting
choices [...] plus that music is still [great]
— but it's more nostalgic rehash than fresh
reimagining."
"Talk about your fixer-upper."
Overall, though, those fortunate enough to
catch the flick early were absolutely blown
away.
All in all, it sure seems like The Lion King
is destined for critical and box office glory
and is likely to be counted as yet another
huge win for Disney.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.